here's how Deadpool kills everybody in
the Marvel Universe part two so the
first person he kills next is Spider-Man
by ironically enough shooting him in the
face with a gun The Avengers Assemble to
try to figure out what to do with
Deadpool but then Jarvis comes running
in saying that Dr Hank Pym is missing
come to find out Deadpool had used PIN
particles to shrink down bombs and then
basically regrew them all in front of
the Avengers and blew pretty much all of
them to Pieces but because Luke Cage has
Bulletproof Skin and Thor's nearly
indestructible they survive so Deadpool
had put miniaturized bombs inside of
Luke Cage's coffee so when Luke Cage
drank it the bombs detonate and they
blow Luke Cage up from the inside out
and they kill him following that Thor
attacks Deadpool he throws his hammers
Hammer misses but then Deadpool uses
pimp particles to make the hammer
gigantic so when it gets back to Thor it
crushes him to death finally The
Incredible Hulk kills Deadpool but
because Deadpool can regrow from
anything he comes back and then finds
Bruce Banner when he goes back to his
human form and then cuts his head off
make sure you guys follow for part three